most 67 year olds when they hear a song
like mr brightside but the killers
probably think not for me get the pipe
out the slippers and just slouch in
front of the tv watching love island
repeats but not our guy because last
night was on saturday night the killers
were playing at old trafford in
manchester
and somebody went crowd surfing
[Music]
[Applause]
well doug james 67 decided to just get
airborne for about 35 to 45 seconds
uh unfortunately he then fell
on his head
causing himself
quite nasty injuries he was fine but
he's the killer's lead singer brandon
flowers he they paused the performance
to make sure he was all right with blood
steaming from doug's head and then uh
doug taking the crowd's cheers obviously
now my first reaction i'm joined now by
by doug james and his son baz who's with
him doug first of all how are you
i'm absolutely fine i've just got a few
aches you know with their own muscles
early but otherwise perfectly fine good
well my first reaction was what is this
lunatic doing at 67 going crowd surfing
at a killer's concert and then i thought
about it doug and i realized you're
actually an inspiration to all of us who
are now hurtling through middle age
towards 67 and i now want to go crowd
surfing you've become an inspiration to
me
excellent
excellent but let me ask you
you're crowd surfing
on a technical point like doug when you
were actually airborne did you not worry
that this might prove to be the last
thing you ever do on earth
oh no no no no
you cannot worry like that you you've
got to trust the crowd go with it you
know and you feel you know you can feel
that they're supporting you underneath
admittedly i did have a few dips and the
last it was quite a big dip but never
mind it was it was good fun and i
enjoyed it i'm joined now by the world
leading expert dr max tegma professor of
physics at mit institute for artificial
intelligence in massachusetts so one of
the most brilliant ai minds in the world
welcome to you uh before we start the
interview i wanted to play you a clip
from an interview i did with professor
stephen hawking actually in his last
ever television interview before he
sadly died in which we talked about the
threat from ai
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it there is a
greater danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing for then it can improve
itself rapidly and we may lose control
so that's what professor stephen hawking
said what do you what do you think of
that and what do you think of what's
happened with this google engineer
i agree with stephen hawking i actually
had the honor to work with him and we
wrote an op-ed together
where we argued that
artificial intelligence is going to be
either the best thing ever to happen to
humanity or the worst thing so the most
the interesting challenges well
how can we steer it in a good direction
with lennox lewis we were we were stuck
together for about six weeks and became
good friends and i've got a lot of time
for lennox but he told me when he was
the heavyweight champion of the world
when he used to go out clubbing
especially in sort of new york and so on
yeah uh the biggest guy in every place
they went at some stage of the night
would come and try it on want to have a
fight
do you get that
yeah
do you know what great question no i
don't get it anywhere because i don't
walk around like i'm a heavyweight
champion of the world i've not got a
chip on my shoulder and my aura is come
here while i give you a hug and think he
was hung my auras not let me punch you
in the face i'm a tough guy
so never once in my whole life yeah i
can vouch for that i've never ever seen
it no one has ever approached me for a
fight or approached me in aggressive
manner no because i'm not that i've not
got that aura or edge on me where i need
to prove myself or whatever you're not
like aggressive macho man are you no i'd
rather just sing and dance and have a
beer and whatever else we brits have
always enjoyed a glass of french
champagne but now there's a new english
bubbly in town the sparkling wine from
my own county of sussex has been given a
champagne style status but how does it
compete well i'm joined now by the
french maitre d fred syriacs along with
former cricketer turned winemaker lord
ian both of well beefy let me start with
you
uh because i know that you have a rival
vineyard in neighboring kent to sussex
you must be feeling gutted tonight that
my county is stuffed
well actually not really because if i
can show you the bottle uh
uh
the bell for wine rose
was uh in bottle
the one that was bottled in 2004
and vintage as it was shown at the show
in paris in a blind tasting
and the judges when they were horrified
when they pulled off the the bag and
there was a bottle of balfour
rose sparkling and we're not allowed to
call it champagne but i think we will
from now on so what you're saying
wine is actually superlative that's what
you're saying
of course
what else would you expect now i
wouldn't expect you to ever look it it's
good i wouldn't expect you to ever put
french wine above anything english but
is it just to be serious for a moment
how good is the stuff we're now
producing here does it deserve this kind
of comparative status
i think it's for quite some time now
along the south south coast of england
um
the the wines have improved so much and
maybe something to do with the weather
the warming up but um
it's been fantastic all the way along
the coast you can find really good
particularly sparkling sparkling lines
stanley it's great to see you uh as
always an effervescent presence and you
are a cheater i've got to tell you piers
you know you lured me in here it was a
bit like cecil the lion
i'm a trophy hunter i learned him
i don't think i'm a trophy there's
nothing wrong with defending your son by
the way and we got to talk about trophy
hunting and your book and i showed you
doing a handstand the world's looking
for stanley are thank you peers
good to see you
see you all folks
tell boris to come in soon we'd have fun
cheers dally good to see you
i think he's going to get boris out of
the fridge to get him on the show